Mà 1,5 tổng thống Mỹ đoán trang tuyên bố Mỹ và Trung Quốc đã thiết kết một thổ thổng thương mạnh,
lấy giống bước tiến quan trọng, sau các vòng đàn phán kăng thẳng tại Trinney và Lâm Đông.
Pháp biểu tại nhà trắng ông trăm không tiếp lộ chí tiếp, sẵn khẩn định, thoại thuận đã được kỹ ngày hung qua.
Một quan trưng ngày thẳng cho biết đây là phán bản bổ xong, nhằm thiết lập cơ trẻ thực hiện cho các nổi dùng đặt được,
tại Trinney, khối tháng năm, Trung đỏ có vệ các sạm thuyên quan trong chiếm mấy ngày để tư tục đàn phán một thịp định toàn diện.
Truy đó, thì tiến chính này tình dưới vật cảnh bế tăng giống bắt đồng về sức khẩu đất hiếm và kìm xác công nghệ.
Một trưng tại chính Mỹ, Scorb Bên xe và đại diện thương mạnh trên mươi dân crier đàn xanh đầu đoán đàn phán tự lưng đồn,
nơi đàn được sức đồng thuận cuối cùng với phó thu tự trung Quốc hà lập pham.
Trung khi phía Mỹ khẳng định thỏ thận đá hoàn tất, đại xe quan Trung Quốc tại Washington từ chối bình luận.
Chúng ta có đồng kinh gió anh Mỹ chung ông Sons Sting đánh giá, nếu thổ thận mang lại xe ông định và công bằng,
thì sẽ là một khẳng lợn lớn cho cả hai đơn nước.
Huyện Mỹ vẫn sửa thủy bổ xung hai me vấn trang với thoàn bộ hàng hoá Trung Quốc,
bây giờ li ra liên quan đến vấn đề phía ta liên.